y una caída a nivel mundial el conjunto
de aplicaciones de facebook que incluye
instagram y whatsapp experimentó fallas
que afectaron a millones de usuarios el
gerente de tecnología de facebook se
pronunció por medio de twitter las más
sinceras disculpas a todos los afectados
por las interrupciones de los servicios
de facebook en este momento estamos
experimentando problemas de red y los
equipos están trabajando lo más rápido
posible para depurar y restaurar todo lo
más rápido posible varios expertos
aseguraron que el problema pudo deberse
a las conocidas como dns que permiten
que las direcciones lleven a los
usuarios a sus destinos se trató de una
caída insólita porque a pesar de que las
interrupciones en las redes son comunes
las globales y superiores aún ahora son
extrañas los más afectados fueron los
usuarios
a mí me encanta esta gran es la
aplicación que más uso especialmente
para mi trabajo así que profesionalmente
es un paso atrás y luego personalmente
siempre estoy en la aplicación así que
apesta es lo peor
otros en cambio aprovecharon la
desconexión y recordaron cómo se vivía
en un mundo sin las redes sociales
pero en el panorama general creo que el
mundo sería un mejor lugar si todo el
mundo no supiera lo que hacen todos los
demás todo el tiempo cada segundo cada
minuto del día
en la tarde el valor de las acciones de
facebook bajo cerca de un 5%